قبل شهرين
،
أطاح الجيش بحكومة منتخبة ديمقراطيًا في انقلاب بعد أن
عانى الجيش مما لا يمكن
وصفه إلا بأنه هزيمة مذلة
في الانتخابات التي أجريت في نوفمبر الماضي ،
حيث أدى الانقلاب إلى ظهور
حركة احتجاجية هائلة انتشرت في جميع
أنحاء البلاد.
وببساطة ، فإن الجيش لا يحظى
بدعم شعب ميانمار ، ومع
تضخم تلك الاحتجاجات
وأصبح الناس أكثر غضبًا
من هذا الانقلاب ،
وكذلك القمع العنيف
لحركة الاحتجاج من قبل الجيش كما
قلتم
قتل المئات.  من بينهم
عشرات الأطفال الذين
أردنا القدوم إلى هنا للإبلاغ على
الأرض لأن ببساطة
لم يُسمح لصحفيين دوليين
بدخول جون إلى ميانمار منذ حدوث هذا الانقلاب ،
فقد جئنا الآن
بإذن من الجيش مع
كل التعقيدات التي
ينطوي عليها ذلك ولكن  ما زلنا نشعر أنه كان من
الأهمية
بمكان أن نأتي إلى هنا بأنفسنا لنرى
ما حدث
نينج ولمواجهة الأشخاص المسؤولين
عن
العنف وهكذا كلاريسا أعني أنني أعرف أن كل
هذا حساس ولكن نظرًا لأنك
تحت رعاية
الجيش ، يمكنك الإبلاغ بحرية ،
فقد تم التأكيد لنا قبل المجيء إلى هنا
بأننا  يتمتعون بالاستقلال
وحرية الحركة ،
أردنا الإقامة في فندق في
يانغون لم يكن مسموحًا به ، ولكننا نقيم
بدلاً من ذلك
في هذا المجمع العسكري ، إنه
مغلق تمامًا ولا يمكننا
الدخول والخروج والتحرك بحرية
أه في يومنا الأول كنا
نتحرك  مع قافلة من
ست شاحنات مليئة بالجنود بالإضافة
إلى أن لدينا العديد من المراقبين الذين
يتابعون كل تحركاتنا كلما سنحت لنا
الفرصة للتواجد في الشارع
الذي
نادرًا ما يقوم
مراقبونا بتصوير كل شيء
بهواتفهم المحمولة يدونون الملاحظات.  المكالمات
الهاتفية تسجل سجلات لكل شخص
نتحدث إليه
وكل حركة نقوم بها ، لذلك
لم تكن بدون تحدياتها
بشكل جيد فهم يأخذون الصورة  res وهم
يأخذون الأسماء على ما يبدو كلاريسا ، لذا
أخبرنا عن الأشخاص
الذين تم احتجازهم بعد التحدث
معك ،
لذلك كان هذا حادثًا مؤلمًا للغاية يا
جون في أحد الأيام ، سُمح لنا أخيرًا
بالذهاب إلى مكان عام لسوق مفتوح
و  من المهم التأكيد هنا على
أننا لم نطلب الاتصال
بأي ناشط مع أي شخص يشارك
في حركة الاحتجاج لأننا نعلم في
ضوء السياق الذي نحن
فيه ومدى خطورة
ذلك عندما أخذنا كاميراتنا في
هذا السوق  وبدأوا في تصوير الفيديو
بدأ الناس في القدوم إلينا بدأ الناس في
تقديم تحية ألعاب الجوع ذات الأصابع الثلاثة
التي
أصبحت رمزًا لهذه الحركة الجريئة
وصعدوا وبدأوا في إخبارنا
بقصصهم التي أخبرونا أنهم
خائفون من قولهم
لنا  لا يوجد سلام
هناك وتركناهم
يقولون سلامهم شعرنا أنه من
المهم منحهم الفرصة
لتسجيل جانبهم من القصة في
السجل بعد قليل.
لكننا اكتشفنا أن العديد منهم كانوا
محتجزين ، فركضت امرأة
ورائي بالفعل بينما كنا لا نزال في
السوق يرتجفون مثل ورقة على
الهاتف مع شخص قال إن ثلاثة
أشخاص تحدثنا إليهم
قد تم اعتقالهم بالفعل.
لكن
الفرصة للجلوس مع كبار العسكريين في ميانمار
أه
القيادة العسكرية العليا
للمتحدث باسم الحكومة
وسألناه عن سبب اعتقال هؤلاء الأشخاص وحثناه
على إطلاق سراحهم واستمع ،
وذهبنا إلى سوق في يانغون والكثير
من
اقترب منا الأشخاص لأنهم أرادوا
التحدث إلينا وأرادوا إخبار
جانبهم من القصة ،
اكتشفنا لاحقًا أنه
تم القبض على خمسة منهم على الأقل ، لقد
تحققنا من ذلك بشكل مستقل ، لقد رأينا
أدلة فوتوغرافية
في بعض الحالات لتأكيد ذلك ، هل يمكنك من
فضلك  اشرح
سبب اعتقالك لأشخاص
لتحدثهم معنا
ما هي الجريمة المحتملة التي ارتكبها
هؤلاء الأشخاص ولم يرتكبوا أي جريمة
رأيتها في  أخبار الأمس
وسألت عن عدد الذين تم القبض عليهم
11 تم القبض على قوات الأمن
خشية أن يقوموا باستفزاز
الآخرين وبدء الاحتجاج في
السوق ولهذا تم القبض عليهم
لكن الحكومة ترتب لإطلاق
سراحهم في أقرب وقت ممكن.
مرتاحون جدًا الآن لأن نكون قادرين على
تأكيد أنه
تم إطلاق سراح ثمانية على الأقل من هؤلاء الأشخاص الـ 11 وجميع الأشخاص الثمانية الذين تعرفهم سي إن إن ، وهذه
أخبار رائعة حقًا ، لكن
هذا لا يزال يمنحك فكرة عن
الموقف الذي جعل هؤلاء الأشخاص
يواجهون هنا أنهم لا يستطيعون حتى أن يقولوا
أمام الكاميرا إنهم
خائفون من
أنهم يريدون مستقبلًا أفضل يريدون الديمقراطية
دون أن يتم القبض عليهم ، وهذا هو مدى
تهديد الجيش من
قبل هؤلاء الناس ومن قبل هذه
الحركة الاحتجاجية الشعبية الهائلة